[Music]
congratulations the first season of
cowboy bebop is absolutely amazing it's
going to keep the original fans on their
toes which i absolutely love
um john i need to talk to you about
something that i noticed
you fall backwards a lot
in this first season and i just wanted
to check in with you
did you get vertigo how are you doing
and are you shocked that spike survived
that final fall break it down for me
spike spike is not does not operate by
the rules of a common man
i think he's a cat cats are like able to
fall from three stories down and somehow
land on their feet be like water yeah be
like water
flow
flow flow and splash
oh my gosh but yeah when you guys read
those final scenes of the season one
finale saw that there were some twists
in there that maybe you weren't
expecting what was your initial reaction
daniella
oh well i remember the moment when it
was
all of us and alex hassell uh in a room
and they were walking us through the
script and they were walking us through
when vicious gets his head cut off and
we were all like what
what and i could see alex like sweating
and then it was like but uh it's a
hologram we were like oh
and i just remember that being such a
moment uh where all of us were just like
no way
mustafa what moment made you freak out
yeah i definitely had to really freak
out um
that one i mean i i i didn't get freaked
out but i think that was a moment where
we were all like damn and and this is
where alex gets to find this out that
sucks
it's poor administration
poor syndicate administration you know
what i mean it's just
jesus john i think the fans are gonna be
freaking out though over the fact that
julia's the one that puts that final
bullet into spike and sends him
cascading through the cathedral stained
glass what was your reaction when you
read about that twist
yeah it was uh i was shocked and it was
really fascinating i just uh really
didn't see
the
julia turn coming heel turn coming and
um
i just think it's really cool that what
could have been sort of um just an
iconic character
or an idea you know of a love of a past
love has become a very active
part of the show in an active um
part of the plot you know so um i just
think it was a it was a
a cool misdirect there are so many
cowboy bebop easter eggs hidden
throughout this series what is one that
you're most excited for the fans to see
mustafa no one knows the ship quite like
you were there any easter eggs on there
that you were excited to see on set
um yeah i think if you look on all the
surfaces you're gonna find things that
are like you know the um the
refrigerator there's a homage to the
voice actor for spike the original all
over the surfaces everywhere if you're
paying attention and i think it's one of
those things that you'll pick up more
as you watch it more you know what i
mean like the leftovers will give you
more information about what you're
seeing but yeah it's everywhere it's
everywhere john and daniella was there
anything that you were excited to see on
set i think all of us were excited just
go on on the bebop and look around and
kind of dig around i i was though i was
really hoping i was gonna see a 90210
reference because i couldn't believe
that was in the original anime so i was
like waiting for like jason priestley to
like jump out from around the corner um
but there still is a season two so we'll
see
exactly and speaking of season two i'm
keeping my fingers crossed i need it now
uh but dream with me guys what is
something that you would still like to
see in a season two if we were to get it
i guess i've been saying the
spike this season was
i just could not imagine a more
traumatic series of events for a
character it's hard to imagine
uh where he went and i i feel such
sympathy for the man
he's so broken and he has lost his
reason for living i just want i just
want a nice
i just want a nice day at a cafe for
spike
with a cappuccino
and some friends maybe a new love
interest yeah maybe new love interest
maybe some rose
actually
maybe he could finally get those noodles
maybe yes
maybe maybe maybe some beef in those
noodles you know real beef yeah real
beef
um daniella when i was just chatting
with elena she really wants to see the
julia faye red corvette scene are you
picking up what she's putting down um
yes in fact that was something that
we've talked about that so much like
what are we gonna have our scene
together but she's a potential villain
so
i'm wondering how that's gonna
find its way um but yes of course red
corvette scene like
like
anything you want to see for jet i want
to see jett heal again
from his emotional pain
i want to see him get some vindication
definitely my last question for you guys
i want to talk about the goodest boy in
all the galaxy ein he's such a little
scene stealer what is one thing that you
think fans would be surprised to know
about the real life pup that brought ein
to life did he hit his marks
he was occasionally caught on his mark
by cameras occasionally caught on his
mark uh we all had a handful of treats
at any given time
and it was like
and as soon as those treats aren't there
he's like uh hi no treats okay gotta go
bye
and he weighed literally like 75 pounds
yeah so much hair in my mouth so so he's
a very dense beast a dense little
creature yeah
well daniella i'm just so glad that we
forever have that gif of you riding off
with iron with that sexy wink that's
just like going to be iconic
oh yeah that was a long day of a lot of
hair in the mouth which i think there's
something that's going to be released
showing some more behind behind the
scenes stuff with iron